in a world where digital security is as
crucial as a fortified Castle in
mediable times the role of a cyber
security engineer has never been more
vital did you know that by 2025 the
global cost of cyber crime is expected
to hit an astonishing $10.5 trillion
annually that's double the figure from
just a few years ago with each headline
the demand for skilled cyber security
engineers skyrockets and there's a 3.5
million unfulfilled cyber security jobs
predicted globally by 2025 the average
salary of a certified cyber security
engineer in the United States is
approximately $97,000 per year and it's
consistently one of the highest paying
it certifications but how does one
become a part of this Elite Force where
do you start and what's the fastest
route to not just enter But excel in
this high stakes Arena and in this video
we will cover this and before commencing
if you are an aspiring cyber security
professional looking for online training
and certification from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts to enhance your
credibility then search no more simply
learns postgraduate program in cyber
security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
a right choice this course is designed
to accommodate a diverse range of
Learners and this course requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% of average
and no prior programming experience is
required and one plus year of work
experience is preferred for more details
you can use the link in the description
box and pin comment and if these are the
types of videos you would like to watch
then hit the subscribe button like and
press on the Bell icon to never miss on
future content so stay tuned with us
until the end of this video and don't
forget to register your opinion in the
comment section below now let's explore
the fastest way to become a cyber
security engineer in 2024 so now let's
get started with who is a cyber security
engineer so cyber security engineer is a
professional who specializes in
protecting Computer and Network systems
from digital attacks so these attacks
can include hacking breaches viruses and
various forms of cyber threats so now
we'll see the roles and responsibilities
of a cyber security engineer so first
role and responsibility for a cyber
security engineer is system protection
that is implementing and managing
Security Solutions to protected systems
networks and data this includes
firewalls antivirus software and
intrusion detection systems and then
comes threat assessment so continuously
monitoring and assessing the cyber
security or the security of computer
system and networks identifying
potential vulnerabilities that could be
exploited by hackers and then comes the
incident response so responding to and
investigating cyber security breaches or
any type of cyber security incident this
involves not only addressing the
immediate threat but also conducting
post stent analysis to prevent future
incidents and then comes security
planning so developing and implementing
security policies and protocols they
ensure that an organization's data and
infrastructure are protected against
potential attack
and then comes regular update and
maintenance so keeping systems updated
and patched against non vulnerabilities
which is crucial in defending against
rapidly evolving cyber threats and then
comes collaboration so working with
other it professionals such as Network
administrators and software developers
to ensure that security considerations
are integrated into all facets of
Technology operations and then comes
Education and Training to educating
staff and users about good security
practices like identifying fishing
attempts and securing personal data so
these are the roles and responsibilities
of a cyber security Engineers now we'll
see the essential skills needed to
become a cyber security engineer so
certainly here's a list of essential
skills and we'll start with the one that
is strong understanding of networking so
cyber security Engineers need to have a
deep understanding of networking
protocols how data travels across
networks and the vulnerabilities
associated with different network
configurations and then comes
programming and scripting that is
Proficiency in programming languages
like python C C++ and scripting
languages is crucial for writing custom
exploits and tools and then comes cyber
security fundamentals so a solid grasp
of basic cyber security Concepts
including threats vulnerabilities risk
assessment management and security
principles is fundamental and then comes
operating systems so familiarity with
various operating systems including
Windows Linux and Unix is essential for
understanding their vulnerabilities and
security configurations and then comes
web application and security knowledge
of web Technologies web application
vulnerabilities such as SQL injection
crite scripting and security best
practices for web development and then
comes the penetration testing tools so
Proficiency in tools like Metasploit and
map wre shock bub suit and other
penetration testing tools used to assess
system vulnerabilities and then comes
cryptography that is understanding of
encryption decryption crypto graphic
algorithms and their role in securing
data and then comes wireless security so
expertise in wireless network security
including Wi-Fi encryption protocols and
vulnerabilities and then comes security
compliance and standards so knowledge of
security standards and compliance
regulations such as PCI DSS hiaa and
gdpr and then comes incident response so
being prepared to handle security
incidents and breaches effectively
including forensics and Analysis and
then comes social engineering awareness
so understanding of social engineering
tactics used by attackers to manipulate
individuals into revealing confidential
information and then comes the ethical
mindset so a cyber security engineer
must adhere to a strong code of ethics
and prioritize responsible disclosure
when vulnerabilities are found so these
are the essential skills to become a
cyber security engineer now we'll see
how to become a cyber security engineer
so the first step is build a strong
Foundation or you could have a
bachelor's degree in cyber security so
building a strong Foundation is crucial
in the journey to become a cyber
security engineer so start with a deep
understanding of computer science
mastering the basics of Hardware
software and networks familiarize
yourself with operating systems and
their functionalities entry-level
certifications like com A+ and network
plus are your Stepping Stones ensuring
your grasp The Core Concepts of it a
strong Foundation forms the Bedrock upon
which you will build your ethical
hacking skills and knowledge and then
comes the next that is learn programming
so learning programming is a gateway to
unlocking Endless Possibilities in the
Digital World start by understanding the
basics of coding logic and syntax
explore languages like python known for
its Simplicity or JavaScript for web
development practice regularly work on
real projects and seek online tutorials
and courses Embrace problem solving and
debugging and gradually you will Master
the art of programming that will open
the doors to a world of software
development and cyber security
innovation and then comes understand
cyber security Basics so understanding
cyber security Basics is crucial for any
aspiring cyber security engineer it
involves comprehending the core
principles of protecting digital systems
and data key Concepts include
identifying threats vulnerabilities and
the importance of risk management
certification programs like com Security
Plus can provide an entry point into
this realm these Basics form the
foundation for ethical hacking enabling
individuals to recognize and combat
security weaknesses making the digital
world safer and then comes the fourth
step that is dive into ethical hacking
so dive into ethical hacking is a
critical step on the journey to becoming
a skilled cyber security engineer so
during this phase you will focus on
horning your penetration testing skills
and mastering the art of ethical hacking
the certified ethical hacker
certification will be your companion
providing you with the knowledge and
tools to identify vulnerabilities and
secure systems you will explore real
world scenarios test networks and learn
to think like a hacker while maintaining
ethical standards this this stage
prepares you to safeguard digital
Landscapes effectively and then comes
continue learning so continuing learning
in ethical hacking is essential the
cyber security landscape evolves rapidly
so staying up to date is a must explore
Advanced certifications like cissp and
certified ethical hacker to deepen your
knowledge follow industry news blogs and
research to remain informed about
emerging threats join ethical hiking
communities attend conferences and
engage in ongoing practice to hor your
skills remember univers learning keeps
you at the Forefront of cyber security
and ensures you are well prepared to
protect digital assets and then there's
the step six that is gain practical
experience so gaining practical
experience in ethical hacking is crucial
for horning your skills participate in
Capture the Flag competitions where you
can solve real world challenges and
learn to think like a hacker explore
Hands-On labs and exercises that allow
you to practice various hacking
techniques in a controlled environment
engage with ethical hacking communities
share knowledge and collaborate on
projects to build a strong practical
foundation in cyber security and then
comes the step seven that is seek
employment so to seek employment as a
cyber security engineer craft a resume
highlighting your skills certification
and experience look for opportunities in
Industries such as Finance Healthcare
and tech companies where cyber secur is
par amount network with Professionals in
the field explore job boards and
leverage online platforms cyber security
Engineers are in high demand so be
proactive in your job search and
showcase your commitment to safeguarding
digital assets and then comes keep
evolving so the world of cyber security
is constantly changing to stay at the
Forefront always be curious Embrace new
technologies and adapt to emerging
threats regularly update your skills
earn Advanced certifications and network
with fellow hackers remember the cyber
security landscape evolves and so should
you stay ethical committed and dedicated
to safeg guarding the digital real and
then comes the job roles and average
salary so the first job role is cyber
security engineer
so the cyber security engineer in US
earns as much as
$156,000 perom and then comes in India
that he earns around 8 lakhs perom and
then the next job role is incident
responder so the incident responder
earns around
$15,000 perom in us and 7 lakhs perom in
India and then comes the cyber security
analyst so he earns around
$150,000 perom in us and in India he
earns around 11 lakhs perom and then
comes penetration tester so penetration
tester earns as much as
$145,000 in us and 13 lakhs perom in
India and then comes the cyber security
consultant so the cyber security
consultant earns around $120,000 perom
in us and 10 lakhs perom in India now
see the companies hiring cyber security
Engineers so the first is Amazon asena
Google Apple and Intel so these are the
top most companies and there are way
more companies that are hiring for the
cyber security engine senior RS so with
this we have come to the end of this
session and there you have it folks we
hope you enjoyed this insightful
tutorial if you like this session then
like share and subscribe if you have any
questions then you can drop them in the
comment section below thanks for
watching and stay tuned for more from
Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here